these different projects and different
companies everybody has goal and a
principal and freedom of expression for
example and Freedom of Information I
know is at the heart of Tommy and for me
that makes me comfortable I don't have
to worry about any CEO going off I don't
have to worry about anything happening
that is the platform and I feel more
comfortable you know YouTube for example
has YouTube kids which is just like
indoctrinating young kids within this
rainbow indoctrination and it's really
dangerous these three corporations will
control everything so how do you see the
future of the internet